bienvenidos a este programa especial
dedicado a las enfermedades físicas y a
la atención médica que quedaron
relegadas a causa de la crisis sanitaria
generada por el coi 19 xoy valentina
torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos durante la pandemia
numerosos países reconocieron que sus
sistemas de salud quedaron colapsados en
medio de un miedo generalizado las
personas dejaron de asistir a controles
exámenes de diagnóstico y procedimientos
menores o ya programados lo que agravó
la incidencia de enfermedades no
transmisibles al tiempo que impactó
padecimientos que ya estaban
desatendidos veamos más al respecto en
el siguiente informe
modo ccoo bit así definen los expertos
lo ocurrido con los sistemas de salud
desde el inicio de la pandemia la
urgencia de investigar y tratar los
padecimientos relacionados con el sars
co2 causante del cobi 19 y el temor
generalizado entre la población hicieron
que se dejaran de lado los diagnósticos
y controles de enfermedades no
transmisibles en nuestra región mueren
cinco y medio millones de personas por
año
de enfermedades crónicas no estamos
hablando enfermedades del corazón
cerebrovasculares cánceres respiratorias
crónicas como el epoc y transtornos
mentales como el depresión suicidio
y desde que empezó la pandemia a esta
parte de kobe han muerto dos millones
trescientos mil o sea que estamos
en términos de números las enfermedades
crónicas tienen una carga de enfermedad
muy pero muy grande exámenes comunes
como citologías endoscopias y pruebas de
laboratorio dejaron de realizarse por
miedo de los usuarios y por falta de
citas lo que retrasó los diagnósticos
asimismo se pospusieron a cirugías
menores y otros procedimientos
programados además de las enfermedades
crónicas hubo otros padecimientos
endémicos que ya estaban relegados o
desatendidos y su situación se agravó
por vectores de malaria
es la región caribe de dengue
en mitad del país
los expertos aseguran que el mundo está
en un momento clave para reformar los
sistemas de salud dejando de tomar a los
usuarios como números para brindar
atención integral añaden que es
fundamental centrar el foco tanto en la
atención primaria como en la medicina
preventiva y resaltan que pese al
complejo panorama actual ya las
lecciones que ha dejado el comité hasta
el momento el mundo no está preparado
para enfrentar futuras pandemias sobre
otros exámenes diagnósticos y
tratamientos que quedaron relegados
conversamos con el doctor riccardo
teijeiro integrante de la sociedad
argentina de infectología y esto fue lo
que nos explicó todo lo que decía los
exámenes cardiológico del seguimiento
cardiológico fueron uno de los más
importantes
y ese tipo de controles se perdieron el
paciente oncológico
el hecho de no poder hacer la evaluación
sistemática que tiene por el diagnóstico
por imagen el seguimiento con imágenes y
ese tipo de cosas que no permitió
hacerle la evaluación correspondiente
son lo que han perdido y esto no hay
vuelta atrás muchos pacientes por esos
problemas éste también han quedado en el
camino ahora hablamos de la mortalidad
materna que no es una enfermedad como
tal sino una problemática que se ha
disparado durante la pandemia los
expertos alertan que la muerte de
gestantes prácticamente se duplicó
frente a cifras pre pandemia al tiempo
que la atención a la madre y al recién
nacido se han interrumpido casi a la
mitad principalmente por el miedo de la
mujer a consultar pero también porque
los recursos se han concentrado en el
commit conversamos con el doctor andrés
vecino investigador de la escuela de
salud pública johns hopkins bloomberg y
esto nos dijo
el principal determinante de un
embarazo exitoso es el cuidado prenatal
la gente dejó de ir a estos servicios
preventivos y al dejarles estos
servicios preventivos se presentan en el
momento en el que ya están en trabajo de
parto con potenciales complicaciones son
personas que
posiblemente tienen tienen
complicaciones que son derivadas de que
no se diagnosticaron sus problemas
tempranamente por cuenta de que no había
servicio de salud disponibles o que
simplemente no querían ir parando porque
también al contagio ahora nos centramos
en la vacunación contra otras
enfermedades un sector que también se ve
afectado porque los esfuerzos se
concentraron en la urgencia de inocular
a la población contra 'el hobbit' 19
según la organización mundial de la
salud de unicef a nivel mundial en 2020
se registró el mayor retroceso desde
2009 23 millones de menores no
recibieron vacunas infantiles básicas en
ese año una cifra que supera en casi
cuatro millones la registrada en 2019 a
su vez la organización panamericana de
la salud alertó de un alto riesgo de
brotes de enfermedades vacunación
rutinaria estos organismos resaltan que
los más afectados son los niños y
adultos que viven en comunidades
golpeadas por conflictos o en lugares
apartados y de escasos recursos al
respecto esto nos dijo el doctor luís
jorge hernández director de
investigaciones en la facultad de
medicina de la universidad de los andes
no hay ningún biológico en la región
industria en vez de el triple viral
sarampión rubéola parotiditis y con un
riesgo de habido brotes de sarampión
desde el año 2000 ediciones 2010 y 9000
y las vacunas protegen casi contra 25
enfermedades son 21 biológicos en el
recién nacido
hay que colocar vacuna contra la croc
los oratorios y melilla pero proteger al
menos de un año de sarampión
x la histeria
latina que me agrade que la influencia
que pueda surgir
de la ope s expuso que en 2021 se
notificaron más de 600 casos de
sarampión en brasil alrededor de medio
centenar en eeuu y cinco en guayana
francesa a su vez en septiembre de 2021
la ms informó de siete casos de fiebre
amarilla en humanos y 10 en primates en
el noreste de venezuela en los estados
de monagas y anzoátegui el mismo
organismo alertó sobre el aumento en los
casos y muertes por malaria en 2020 a
nivel global
hubo 241 millones de casos y 627 mil
muertes 14 millones de contagios más que
en 2019 y 69 mil fallecimientos
adicionales esto afirma el doctor
teixeiro la atención del paciente y lo
muy demorado y los calendarios de
vacunación disminuyeron muchísimo la
cobertura eso qué pasa hace que la
región empezamos a tener brotes de
enfermedades que teníamos controladas en
este momento tenemos un brote de
sarampión hay más de 600 casos de
sarampión en brasil donde ya está
registrado dos muertos dos niños muertos
y sabemos que es una enfermedad
totalmente prevenible por una cosa que
al disminuir las coberturas corremos
estos riesgos eso es una de las
enfermedades que tenemos que tener muy
en cuenta a la vez también tenemos
brotes de malaria que están habiendo en
distintos sectores y de fibra amarilla
que también hay en brasil en venezuela o
sea son cuidades que tenemos que tener
la región y tenemos que empezar a mirar
nuevamente en cómo lograr controlar
estas propiedades pese a que parece que
todos los efectos de las pandemias
fueron negativos los expertos resaltan
avances en materia sanitaria ocurridos a
raíz del hobbit 19 esto expuso la
doctora beatriz champaña coordinadora
regional de la coalición latinoamerica
saludable plantes la salud se veía con
menos prioridad y ahora el kobe nos ha
dado
bueno así una una bofetada que uno se da
cuenta la importancia que tiene la salud
y mantener a la población saludable para
la economía de nuestros países pensemos
también digitalización está ocurriendo
en muchas partes del mundo ahora la
telemedicina
y la inteligencia artificial
son muchos los aprendizajes que pueden
resultar de una situación como la que ha
vivido el mundo en estos casi dos años
es prácticamente una opinión
generalizada que los sistemas de salud
tienen que ser modificados de forma
estructural poniendo la atención
primaria en el centro de la agenda pero
realmente se puede decir que hemos
aprendido de la lección y que el mundo
podría enfrentar otra pandemia en un
futuro cercano esto es lo que afirma el
doctor vecino en este momento no es no
son claras las lecciones en parte no lo
son porque hemos estado en un estado de
emergencia constante hemos estado un
poco intentando y viendo qué funciona y
qué no funciona
y realmente yo creo que no hemos tenido
el tiempo
de mirar para atrás y mirar qué fue lo
que hicimos bien que fue lo que hicimos
mal y cómo prepararnos para la próxima
pandemia
hace un par de semanas salió un índice
actualizado de seguridad
global en salud
y muestra que la mayoría de países de
hecho se encuentran en un índice
bastante bajo de preparación para una
próxima pandemia paradójicamente dos
años después de haber entrado una
pandemia estamos todavía no preparados
para recibir una nueva de la misma forma
el doctor de género asegura que es
probable que la salud deje de estar en
el centro de la agenda en cuanto pase
esta pandemia tal como ha ocurrido con
otras en el pasado creo que va a volver
a pasar vuelve a haber una pandemia la
pandemia gonzález nunca son con tanta
frecuencia
para sanz pedido de seis años ocho años
diez años entonces ese periodo
suficiente para que los gobiernos dejen
de invertir en los sistema de salud y la
nueva pandemia va a sorprender
nuevamente y esto va a seguir pasando la
salud esté para muy poco gobierno
podemos nombrar algunos pero muy poco
gobierno son le dan la importancia que
dividirán por último el doctor hernández
coinciden que el mundo no está preparado
para una nueva pandemia y resalta lo que
históricamente ha ocurrido con eventos
similares al tiempo hace un llamado a
cambiar el modelo de atención ningún
país estará preparado pero no bien que
hay que tener un manejo de pandemias el
mundo no está para manejo de pandemias
no hemos aprendido la lección esto haya
pasado año 2009 la pandemia de h1n1 por
influencias no aprendimos la lección
debíamos tener vigilancia centinela no
la teníamos ya ha habido la belle de
esta pandemia de la que del medioeste
del sas de del síndrome respiratorio
agudo severo y gracia del año 2004 2005
no aprendimos la lección seguimos
dañando los ecosistemas afectando la
barrera hombre animal que rugen nuevas
especies y nuevas enfermedades
emergentes
entonces lo peor que puede pasar es que
sigamos igual esto es una lección para
mejorar la atención primaria diagnóstico
tempranas donde entró oportuno hacer una
medicina más simbad oria mejorar la
calidad de vida de la población
nos cogió con personas desnutridas con
sobrepeso decía no diagnosticadas pues
debemos volcarnos hacia modelos de
atención primaria mucho más preventivos
y reconociendo los determinantes y
ambientales de la sociedad así llegamos
al final de este especial que en la
producción contó con la colaboración de
alva santana a los expertos que
participaron les agradecemos su análisis
y su tiempo ya ustedes les pedimos que
se sigan cuidando y les recordamos que
pueden ampliar toda la información en
france 24 punto com
[Música]